A well-organised email makes you look professional
and is much easier for your reader to understand.
Here are some tips to help you write clear,
organised messages.
It's best to start your email with the reason
you are writing it.
This isn’t as important in informal emails,
but in a business email you shouldn’t waste
time - get to the point!
A good sentence to begin with is ‘I am writing
to…’followed by a suitable verb.
For example, ‘I am writing to ask for more
information about your event’, or ‘I am
writing to inform you of my new postal address’.
Emails are easiest to read if they are broken
up into paragraphs.
Email paragraphs are usually shorter than
in normal writing, with most being two or
three sentences long.
This isn’t a firm rule, but if in doubt,
keep them short.
You should begin a new paragraph each time
you change topic, and each paragraph should
start on a new line.
For example: If you are emailing a colleague
to discuss two issues and plan a meeting,
you should write these in three separate paragraphs.
Many people read emails on their phones, and
long email paragraphs can be frustrating to
read, especially on a small screen.
Last, to make your emails as clear as possible,
you still need to proofread an email before
you send it to avoid any grammar or spelling
errors.
Most email services include a spellchecker
feature to help you do this.
You could also get a friend or co-worker to
check through your message.
Subscribe to our channel for more videos on
how to improve your English language skills.